[Music]
What do you prefer? There is
no power nor strength except with
Allah. This encourages us to pray upon the dead and with your intellect.
And the mosques belong to Allah, so do not invoke anyone besides Allah.
Allah, the Most High, the Most Exalted, said: Your Lord said, "Call upon Me; I will respond to you." Call upon Me,
Allah, the Most High, the Most Exalted. If My servants ask you about
Me, tell them, "I am near." This
encourages us to pray upon
the dead so that they may intercede with Allah. Allah, the Most High, the Most Exalted, said: "If My servants ask you about Me, indeed I am near." This encourages us to pray upon the dead so that they may intercede with Allah. Glory be to Allah.
The people of misguidance are Satanic. The
first to make analogies in religion. May
Allah bless you. Peace and blessings be upon him. May Allah bless
you, my brother.
Supplication is worship. May
Allah,
the Most High, bless you. Okay, now you understand correctly.
Abu Bakr, may Allah bless him and grant him peace, said: The
Quran of the Companions: Whoever worshipped Muhammad, then Muhammad has
died. And whoever worshipped Allah, then Allah is alive and does not
die. Muhammad, peace and blessings be upon him. Muhammad, peace and blessings be upon him.
His worship  Muhammad, peace and blessings be upon him.
God, my
brother, may God bless you. Wait,
you can give me one from the Quran. You can give me one
propet. You can give me one from any of the ones, but now
you're saying to
meas the trying to establish the same
like trying to establish in opposition
to the text of the Quran and the Sunnah, and that is a may Allah, Subhana, guide you lead
to Hell. When he said, "I'm
better than Adam. You created me from you. You created him from clay." He may be in opposition to the text of the Quran and the Sunnah. In fear of God, no, I don't want, my brother. You don't have anything to explain. You can give me one statement of any of the ones.
God, the Most High, the Almighty,
has revealed to you and to those before you, "If you associate others with Allah, I will surely
love
your deeds and be among the losers." God, the Most High, the Almighty, has revealed to you, "If you associate others with Allah, I will surely love your deeds and be among the losers." Praise be to God,
the Most High, the Almighty.
If you give me, you can give me, you
can give
the Companions